I don't understand how we have an
internet which is censoring free speech
and information the internet was created
as this alternative to mainstream media
as this protocol this platform whereby
everybody has the opportunity to access
it but in more recent years we've seen
the rise of censorship they're now
branding things as misinformation big
Tech is working with governments in
order to push political agendas this is
why we so desperately need an
alternative or a decentralized internet
and the only alternative internet that
I'm seeing is Tommy net who are doing
some amazing things the Tommy team are
focused on free speech and free
information regardless of where you are
in the world and whatever government
restrictions there are and this is
exactly what I believe in as a Creator I
don't want to live in a world whereby
I'm not allowed to voice my opinion or
if I voice my opinion I'm gonna get shut
down and demonetized especially when
what I'm saying is true